je vous parle de ça j'ai quasiment les
coups de pleurer parce que ça fait très
très mal les souvenirs sont douloureux à
l'image des six mois d'enfer que le zona
a fait vivre à Linda brosso il a fallu
que j'arrête de travailler il a fallu
gérer de me promener parce que je
pouvais même pas dire m'asseoir
sur un bain presque 6 ans plus tard elle
n'a toujours pas reçu le vaccin contre
le zona qui coûte près de 300 dollars
pour les deux doses requises non moi je
suis pas prête à me faire vacciner à
payer 300 dollars pour un vaccin là
c'est trop cher pour vous oui c'est trop
simple pour moi ce sont finalement les
personnes de 80 ans et plus et les
adultes immunodéprimés qui auront droit
au vaccin gratuitement dès le mois de
mai quand j'ai vu l'annonce j'étais un
peu choqué parce que pour moi
c'est comme à partir de 50 ans c'est
aussi la vie du Comité sur
l'immunisation du Québec qui avait
recommandé il y a 5 ans que le vaccin
soit offert gratuitement à toute
personne de plus de 50 ans est un mec
les quantité de vaccins sont assez
limités c'est pas réaliste de d'emblée
d'offrir le vaccin à tous les 50 ans et
plus mais pour ce membre du comité
l'annonce d'aujourd'hui demeure un pas
dans la bonne direction bon ceux qui ont
environ 600 personnes qui vont à
l'hôpital à chaque année à cause du zona
c'est beaucoup les gens de 80 ans et
plus disons que c'est une belle avancée
même son de cloche à la fadoch qui
demande toutefois que la gratuité
s'étendra rapidement au 65 ans et plus
bien des personnes de 65 ans et plus
n'ont pas le portefeuille dont Paul est
fond pour se payer ce vaccin-là aucun
représentant du gouvernement n'était
disponible pour une entrevue et par
communiquer Québec précise que l'accès
au vaccin gratuit contre le zona pourra
être élargiée pour des prochaines années
ici Mathieu papillon Radio-Canada
Montréal